but babe moving out please this is the  worst possible time please don't do this  Dave garbage huh  okay I'll take your garbage yeah sure  you know I find the more garbage in the  can the better it feels to dump it all  out I suppose that's why we let it get  so full in the first place so we can  start over  here to fix the copier yes you're sure  hey how did you solve things a really  broken that's the way we treat them it  needs to be fist who the hell are you  guys the important question is who are  you Steve well if it isn't mr. Stanley  Carl  [Music]  you need to banjo will trouble white boy  I was here first  Tommy can't sweep this  [Music]  trust the field  they're from the only warlin magical  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  good lord or you alright well I guess  sometimes things have to come apart  before we can put them back together  again  oh you're a magical negro too who you  call a negro [ __ ]  you